hey youtubers is Charlie so the TV show
just confirmed a big theory from the
books that George R Martin has been
hinting about the direwolves for a long
time in the larger role they have to
play in the war for the dawn there are a
couple small changes based on the things
the TV show is doing that I'll try to
explain as we go along if you're finding
me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get everything we're doing
Game of Thrones all year long even
during the off season so be sure to
click that bell so you don't miss any of
the videos but as sad as that Nymeria
scene was from episode two it confirmed
a big book theory that george RR martin
has also hinted at that might come back
into play later in the series not
necessarily this season but in season 8
there's always been a lot of confusion
about what the show is doing with
direwolves because we don't see ghosts
hardly ever I mean where is ghost right
now John's going to Dragonstone and he's
leaving ghosts behind he would never
leave ghosts behind so there's some TV
show quirks that we have to explain at
the end of this but the theory that was
confirmed was the Nymeria super pack the
thing that we've been talking about for
the last couple years I think it was a
couple years ago when season four was
happening and George our Martin was
still doing more public engagements
where he would answer questions people
were like where's Nymeria Aria keeps
having these wolf dreams in the books
where's Nymeria she's got to be alive
somewhere out there and he confirmed yes
she's still alive and without
necessarily confirming the role that
Nymeria would play just said that there
would be some importance to her coming
back later in the story in this scene is
not what he was talking about just like
having a moment with aria this is one of
those moments that the TV show uses to
help bump Aria in the right direction
and also touch on something that
happened way back in season 1 when she
let Nymeria go there's a couple
different parts to the super-pac theory
this scene only confirmed part of it
the other part of the theory that
hopefully the show does not fall asleep
on is the fact that nightmare II a
super-pac will be a great weapon of mass
destruction for the forces of good in
the war for the dawn so the really cool
thing about this this will get you
excited for later this is one of those
things that the TV show has only hinted
at they might not do it but fingers
crossed because it involves
characters with special powers that you
haven't seen them used before way back
during dance with dragons before Jon
Snow had been assassinated by the
traitorous brothers of the Nights Watch
damn you ollie John is having a dream
seeing through ghost eyes he's
effectively having a wolf named war gang
without knowing about it ghost is
running around hunting somewhere south
of the wall in the dream ghost is aware
of the presence of Nymeria shaggy dog in
summer the dire wolves that are still
alive he gets woken from the dream when
a raven comes in so that's really the
end of it but one it hints at the fact
that John does have the ability to work
which George our Martin has confirmed
whether or not he ever actually explores
that remains to be seen but too it hints
at the larger connection the more
mythological connection that the wolves
have amongst themselves as well as with
their star children that they bonded to
so ghosts
for instance knows that gray wind has
died even though he wasn't in proximity
to him when he did they have this
supernatural pack connection that will
come back into play during the war for
the dawn so you have to imagine that
this wolf pack that Nymeria has around
her here is actually pretty small
compared to what it's supposed to be in
the book like when Martin teases super
pack he's talking about a giant pack of
wolves led by Nymeria so if you remember
how grey wind was so good in battle
during the war of the five kings think
about how valuable Nymeria would be
against the army of the dead with a
giant pack of wolves they would be
badass all by themselves
even if they weren't being ward by one
of the star children like brand now
here's where we get into some TV show
changes we've seen turnip brand who's
sort of phasing in and out of
consciousness as he continues to access
his powers and look into the future look
into the past try and find out what's
going to happen and how to make sense of
it so if anybody is going to be warding
Nymeria and the other dire wolves during
the series it's probably going to be
brand in the books that's going to be
different and I know everybody always
wonders if brand is able to work a
dragon it's totally possible but think
about the connections that Daenerys has
with drogon how he came to save her
during the end of season five he just
sensed that she was in trouble it's the
same thing with the dire wolves and
their stark children so you don't even
Ness
thoroughly need to warg them in order to
get them to do what you want ghost would
know what John was talking about John
wouldn't have to physically control his
mind and force him to attack them but
the whole idea in Abel setting this
season is is that everybody in the
kingdom gets on the same page that they
need to unite against the army of the
Dead we're really only in the earliest
stages of that because Daenerys is still
going after Circe sir she has your on go
destroy Daenerys fleet but the idea is
that by season eight the people that are
still left alive after these minor
conflicts band together and then you
have all these supernatural things come
back into play so you have Daenerys as
dragons
you have the direwolf super pack the
human characters coming together the
animal characters coming together
so just because arya is saying goodbye
effectively - Nymeria in this scene
doesn't mean that this is the last we'll
ever see of her in in reality all that
was happening in this scene is that our
he's just recognizing that she's not a
pet like that's not you that's what she
was saying this is actually what Dan and
Dave said about it in the behind the
scenes clip the scene harkens back to
season 1 we last saw in the mirror when
aria made her run away because she
wanted to save the myriad life she knew
Circe was going to kill her if she found
her when she finally finds the mirror
again or in the mirror finds her and she
of course wants her to come back home
with her and be her loyal companion
again but the merriest found your own
life that's not you is a direct
reference to what aria herself said to
her father when her father painted this
picture for her of the life she could
have as a lady of a castle and marrying
some Lord and wearing a nice frilly
dress that's not me
Aria is not domesticated and it makes
total sense that her wolf wouldn't be
either and once the wolf locks away at
first she's heartbroken to have come
this close
then she realizes that the wolf is doing
exactly what she would do if she were
that wolf taking that into account just
open up a tab in chrome for the next
year and a half or however long takes to
get the season a four Nymeria to come
back and save the day in a big awesome
twist but just to address the more WTF
aspect of the way the show is treated
the dire wolves if they're so important
mythologically to the stark characters
is
the overarching story why does the show
keep pushing them off to the side why
don't we ever see ghosts standing around
one they said early on that they had a
choice they could make the Dragons
bigger or they could make the direwolves
bigger and at a time Dragons were more
important for the TV show but now that
we've gotten to later seasons and they
do have that crazy high budget they
actually do have the money if they
really wanted to do it but the second in
much bigger reason why you don't see
them around it's just because they felt
like they were never able to do them the
way they thought they should like they
just weren't happy with the way they
look standing next to their human
characters so like in this scene here
when she's standing next to Aria they
have her standing way far away and it's
not like Aria standing right next to her
where she can pet her so you're not
seeing any of those effects so they felt
like they just weren't able to achieve a
really good version of that and that's
what you would need in order to have
ghosts around all the time he'd be
standing almost face to face with human
characters he's like a small horse
that's how big he is logistics Oh much
more time to the scenes that they were
already shooting so they felt like it
was easier to just push them off to the
side and start killing off the direwolf
so I think that's the more WTF aspect of
it is that they started killing
direwolves later just as a way to deal
with them let me know in the comments
though when do you think that will see
Nymeria come back with her super pack in
season 8 do you think it'll be a giant
wide crowd shot like it'll be in Knights
of the Vale type moment where they just
ride in you're not expecting them
because I feel like what the show's
tried to do is give characters unique
powers because Aria should be able to
work Nymeria she should be having wolf
dreams but we haven't really seen that
on the show and I think that's just to
make brand seem more special because
he's the character that work is
everything but just remember that Jon
Snow has wolf dreams Aria has wolf
dreams all of the star children who have
dire wolves that are still alive have
them meaning that they have the
potential to warg so hopefully that
answers some dire wolf questions I know
everybody was really confused after the
episode like the intention what's the
show doing with the characters are they
ever going to come back so I might post
another bonus video Sunday leave all
your requests in the comments below I'll
announce the giveaway winner when I post
that while you wait for everything click
here for the trailer for episode 3 and
you can
here for my episode 2 video thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight